as a kid the first group I ever pay dues
to was a group called seek that was a
bunch of green activists college and
high school campuses actually settle in
their first high school chapters and
there's always been I think in the black
middle class a lot of folks have been
active in the green movement in this in
this in this country uh from working
people you've got to make it worth their
while you've got to connect it to
kitchen table as using ways they're very
explicit so you'll see folks you know in
rural Mississippi where a plant that
used to produce some horrible talks and
has exploded getting very involved that
local issue because it's about life and
death it's about their children's health
they get it they understand it Katrina
helped and Haiti you know has helped to
make that case in a more general basis
to work in class folks but what really i
think it has the best opportunity to get
working class black people involved in
the green movement is connecting it to
the opportunity for jobs um connecting
it to the children's health and very
explicit ways very high rates of
respiratory disease in the black
community that come from a very local
environmental contamination and and
there's a real sense that the changes in
the global economy are passing our
neighborhoods and communities by and so
you know i have great hope that the
green jobs movement in this country will
pull in generations of black people who
stood by the sidelines in that battle
because because no one had ever made the
connection for them about you know how
this actually would make their lives
better
you